[Music]
this morning on the dish acclaimed food
writer and cookbook author Mark Bittman
born in New York he worked a variety of
jobs after college including teacher cab
driver and community organizer sounds
like Barack Obama eventually he combined
dual interests in him food and writing
to become a restaurant reviewer and that
was just the start of an incredible
media career he became a widely read
columnist for The New York Times and
transformed the papers food section into
a cultural force he's authored almost 30
books the latest of which is dinner for
everyone 100 iconic dishes made three
ways Mark Bittman good morning welcome
to the dish
thank you I'm blushing this is your life
but tell us about this tables well this
is a sort of a little bit of a Greatest
Hits because I understood that you guys
like to eat we do they have jalapeno
poppers basically jalapeno stuff with
cheese grilled I mean this is like my
favorite thing in the world it's shrimp
with olive oil garlic and in this case
we have olives and lemon but that's just
like you can call it scampi you can call
whatever you want but it's the simplest
best shrimp dish to me that there is an
arugula salad with chickpeas oven baked
potatoes fries if you will with olive
oil also and you know we've got to be
seasonal strawberry rhubarb pie place as
we toast you with what are we drinking
oh yeah tequila grapefruit juice where
did it go we heard all the different
jobs but when did it did you know that
food as a profession was something for
you you obviously have a lot I mean
things got really I started writing
about food in 1980 but things are really
interesting around 2000 and because
that's when there's sort of felt like
there was this change when you could
talk about food in its more social
context than I don't mean hanging out I
mean as part of food as a serious
subject like the economy or politics or
whatever it was what you wanted you
wanted to write about politics in the
beginning I did but I just I wanted to
address society's ills if you will I
mean it's a
corny sounding but it's true and by 2000
2005 there were and I was not a pioneer
in this by any means but there were
people doing that and it was like wait I
could start writing about food more
seriously and believe me I love cooking
I love to eat I love cookbooks that
whole thing is an integral and important
part of my life but the opportunity to
then start writing about food as I said
in a social political context that was
irresistible and to me that was really
awesome and you find it significant to
talk to our children about what they eat
I mean in terms of food policy you're
like hey we have got to do a better job
of teaching our kids well I think the
most important when people ask me what
the most important issue is I always say
we have to attack marketing junk to kids
because if we don't teach kids every
year that we wait to teach kids how to
eat well is another year on the other
end that as adults people are getting
sick from eating you know diet is now
the leading cause of chronic disease in
the world surpassing tobacco and we're
not doing much about it we're letting
companies market whatever they want to
market and we're not teaching people the
value of food we're not teaching people
the value of farming we're not teaching
people what's right about this enough
preaching yeah and three things just
three ways to to make dinner well three
things so this book went through a lot
of iterations until I think we hit it
right which is it's it's three different
ways to make iconic dishes like this one
for example but but the first one is
fast because everybody always says well
I don't have enough time today so the
first one is really fast the second one
is vegan because everybody says show me
how to make plant-based dishes that are
satisfying that are fun that it's so on
and the third is a blowout dinner for
company kind of thing which is social
and food is important and yeah let me
have you sign the dish okay you can have
this meal not with
but anyone pastor present who would it
be
this meant my mother I think which who's
who's around and I'm going to see her
after this so I'm fulfill that with
thank you thanks for having and if you
want more on Mark Bittman and the dish
you can head to our website at CBS this
morning calm